Let's look at the solution
to our parity quiz.
We're adding parity to our memory,
which consists of eight arrays.
So now the question is should we
add parity to each row of data?
And then when we read out the row into
the row buffer, we check for parity and
report an error?
Or should we have the modules as is and
just add two more that
will hold a parity?
Both approaches have exactly the same
number of extra bits we're adding, but
the approach of having extra modules
as opposed to changing the modules
is preferable for two reasons.
One is that this way,
we can design these memory arrays.
Both are unprotected and
for protective memories.
The protected memories will just
have additional arrays, but
the design of each array is the same.
If we decided to add parity bits here,
then depending on exactly
how many parity bits we are adding for
how many data bits, and whether we
are having parity at all, we would need
to redesign our memory array every time.
The second reason why using redundancy
at the coarser grain rather then
finer grain tends to work better,
is because let's say the ten array fails
by reading zeroes for the entire row,
this is not such a far fetched error.
In that case what we have is if we have
the parity bits added to each row,
the row still has correct parity.
So a single failure, for
example, in the row decoder
will just read the wrong row,
it still has the right parity.
If however, we separate the modules
with a parity, then each of the modules
will operate on its own so
the error of our row decoder here
will cause this bit now to be wrong
in every eight bit word we read.
But if this other arrays
are still working correctly,
then we can still detect that because
the parity is somewhere else.
So this is kind of similar to
doing geographical distribution
of our computers, for redundancy.
Pretty much the further away
the protection bits are, the more
likely they will protect us against
large failures in any single component.